first my thoughts at the end of day 43
America still in shutdown now I actually
think I could do 3 hours of TV tonight
this is when I really miss my radio show
and I still wouldn't get through all of
the material I have to get through with
you we are asking questions we're doing
the digging that old-time real
journalists used to do you know in the
olden days before Obama worship and
Trump demonization became there 24/7
focus
well most governors and mayor's outside
of the blue states have come to the
realization that it's time to get on
with it it's time to move beyond a 24/7
focus on kovat 19:00 it's time to move
into recovery and renewal not
surprisingly the red states are leading
the way we had a tailored and measured
approach that not only helped our
numbers be way below what anyone
predicted but I also did less damage to
our state going for it a lot of this is
a confidence in building confidence with
the public I believe we can re-engage
our economy while still containing the
coronavirus using these proven
strategies at some point we have to stop
feeding the media on this topic now what
I'm saying here is kind of a statement
against interest because after all our
ratings here at Fox and primetime have
just soared during this pandemic you all
want a different perspective and you get
it from us but tonight I'm speaking to
you as a mom as a friend as an American
and I say it's just it's time that we
take back control over our own lives we
do it smartly and we do it safely
the corona virus is obviously a terrible
tragedy I don't need to say that you all
know that it's also particularly
terrible that China and the w-h-o did so
many things to help this pandemic spread
to our shores and it's unfortunate that
the FDA didn't get the testing working
sooner it's awful that Mayor DeBlasio
Hannity was talking about that took
actions that helped the pandemic spread
throughout New York City as it did and
how much kovat spreading was done in
late February by the crowd that was
gathering around San Fran grin
in Chinatown you should come to
Chinatown precautions have been taken by
our city we know that there is a concern
about tourism traveling all throughout
the world but we think it's very safe to
be in Chinatown and hope that others
will come well they kept coming Nancy
but at this point beyond protecting the
vulnerable beyond funding the scientific
work for therapies medical treatments
there's really not all that much more
that the government can do because you
slap too many new kovat regulations on
businesses and that may end up driving
them into insolvency we need businesses
restaurants all these small businesses
to get back on their feet I think now
more than ever we have to have faith in
American innovation and entrepreneurship
on everything we've worked for otherwise
all of these efforts of the past seven
weeks all of our efforts of the past you
know a couple of centuries you're going
to end up being for naught we've never
allowed a foreign enemy to rob us of our
freedom and we can't let a deadly virus
do it either we didn't shut down America
in 1968 during the Hong Kong flu that
was a global pandemic of the h3n2 virus
it killed a hundred thousand Americans
mostly those 65 and older we fast
forward to our horrific flu season this
year which we touched on briefly last
night now New York's current influenza
season has been one of the worst on
record in the first week of January
10-thousand 76 lab confirmed cases now
for comparison there were three thousand
seven hundred and thirty six such cases
during the same time in the 2018-2019
season in New York now fast forward to
the week ending on March 14th look at
that map well if you see it there it's
dark blue there you go it's dark blue
that's the the color coding for
basically a flu out of control and the
week ending on March 28th well it's
still bad but getting better there it is
but then in the week ending on April 4th
Wow the flu virus is basically gone is
that because of a few weeks of social
distancing now fast-forward it it's hard
to believe that the drop off would have
been that significant given the flu
spread within families especially in
cramped New York metro area apartments
work Ovid also spread really fast and
then there was a really weird drop-off
we've been trying to figure this out
maybe some of you can help us week 12 in
the flu counting weeks kind of weird
they start at the end of August and they
go through the following August but week
12 it's like about the end of March
there were three thousand three hundred
and thirty 36 cases all right
influenza cases in New York but week
thirteen the number dropped to seven
hundred and sixty-four cases that's down
more than seventy seven percent week
fourteen dropped to one hundred and
ninety three cases week 15 dropped to
one hundred and forty three case of the
entire state of New York huh now we
reached out to New York state health
officials and to help us understand
these radical drops in flu cases well
they tried to tell us that drops like
this are normal saying in 2018 weeks ten
eight to ten we saw dropping cases from
thirteen thousand two three six eight
nine that's over ten thousand and two
weeks typical de-seed significant
increase increases or decreases from
week to week but that's not even close
percentage-wise to the two consecutive
weeks of over 70 percent decreases in
flu cases this year now one reason
behind those huge drops could be that at
the end of week 12 and late March
Governor Cuomo did put that state on
lockdown that may have convinced people
to stay home but we don't know that and
neither do state health officials
obviously people were still out of
grocery stores pharmacies and we still
had a lot of essential workers out there
epidemiologists will probably be
debating this for years there's a
natural lag in some data reporting so
we're gonna check back in a few weeks
now we certainly do not wish to think
that influenza death
this horrible flu season in New York are
being logged in correctly is covetous we
don't want to think that that would
erode the public's trust in the experts
we can ask questions we can say are
people dying at home with Co vyd or are
they dying at home with a regular flu
but they're fearful of going to a
hospital are those cases being logged at
all we may never know but remember even
when early on we were warned that this
flu season was going to be particularly
deadly we didn't pull kids from schools
remember we played those clips from you
for you last night people were warning
about this is gonna be one of the worst
on record but still we didn't require
people to wear masks on planes or in
grocery stores and
we didn't decide to ruin our economy but
then kovat hit and it was like this flu
season we were hearing about is gonna be
so horrific never even happened at all
the media never talked about it and even
our infectious disease specialists
didn't really address it as time went on
why I think we need answers so we can
move forward with a full understanding
of what actually happened here and how
deadly kovat really was now will face
more viruses in the future we know that
of course we will and we cannot allow
them to bring us to a standstill like
just happen we can't do it again
don't forget we have influenza vaccines
a lot of you probably get them and we
still have a horrendous mortality number
this year and in previous years the flu
vaccine is by any estimate from 45% to
55% effective in a year against all the
various different types of the virus now
no one can say that any Democrat and
looking at everything we've talked about
over the last several weeks
you cannot say honestly that any
Democrat on the scene now would have
handled this crisis markedly better look
at what KOMO is being accused of now
with this stuff going on with the senior
homes the president solved the vents
problem for the blue states like New
York hospital ers were not overwhelmed
that was the goal of flattening the
curve that was his mission accomplished
but in a real way he really accomplished
that mission he and his team have
devoted day and night to helping America
through this terrible time they deserve
gratitude instead they get endless grief
meanwhile House Democrats we talked
about it announced today they're not
even come back to town anytime soon so
they're protecting themselves and their
own comfort as Americans continue to
suffer
how can anyone take Congress seriously
when they're not even here
the people are watching them and I hope
learning learning who's on their side
who's fighting for them who wants them
to get back to their pre kovat lives as
soon and as safely as possible and those
my thoughts at the end of day 43 America
in shutdown